we're now just days away from e3 where
we'll learn about a bunch of new games
we can play down the road but for
PlayStation Plus subscribers June is
also another month with new free games
to claim if you want to know what's on
the table for June I've got you covered
but sadly there are no cross-buy titles
this time around first up on ps4 is XCOM
- if you haven't played the tactical
strategy game before you're in for a
hardcore session of soldiers vs. aliens
your troops can and probably will die
but it's all a necessary sacrifice for
saving the earth also coming to ps4 is
trials fusion which carries on the
series combination of dirt bike racing
and obstacle platforming fusion gives
the game a futuristic setting and with
that comes a new quad bike option for
some stages plus a full-on level creator
things get futuristic on ps3 - with
ghost recon future soldier just like
trials a new setting means new gear like
active camouflage and a personal drone
for your ghost to command as you battle
across Africa Asia and Europe maybe
you'd rather fight zombies instead of
soldiers for you there's zombie driver
HD complete edition oh and instead of
holding the weapons yourself they're
mounted on your vehicle drive right over
or shoot the zombies it's up to you as
for Vita you can get competitive with
atomic ninjas each of these little guys
can leap all around the battlefield but
the only way to defeat your opponents is
to knock them into traps or off the map
it's an interesting concept for you to
try out across capture the flag and
deathmatch modes but you can also slow
things down on Vita with squares your
goal here is to make each one of the
said squares a certain color but it's
not as simple as it sounds different
kinds of squares and 80 levels means
plenty of puzzle solving and you can
build your own stages - and those are
your free PS plus games for June they'll
be available from Tuesday June 5th until
July 2nd remember that you can always
check out gameplay clips and reviews for
these titles over on GameSpot and if you
want to watch us discuss news like this
you can tune in to GameSpot daily that
airs weekdays at 11 a.m. Pacific
[Music]